this question comes underneath a topic
called radian
measure radians are you recall that way
of measuring angles instead of degrees
different unit which helps us to do
things especially with circles and also
with trigonometric
functions but in this case we're going
to measuring a whole bunch of different
things to do
with this circle because of the
questions that are imposed to us so
let's have a go and see what this
question means and how to answer it's
qui
answer the different things that's
posing to us the dark border bar has a
radius of 23
centimeters so you can see that distance
being measured in here
from the center um and then it goes up
to the top here it doesn't include um by
the looks of this
this particular boundary here uh it does
include this this sort of um
you know border which has all the
numbers written on it so there's the
radius
the shaded area has a height of seven
millimeters
which you can see measured in there uh
and the first thing i immediately note
before doing any solving or anything
like that
is that this diagram totally out of um
not to scale like it's not it's out of
proportion
um this seven millimeters is uh
what's less than one centimeter
obviously so it's less than one twenty
third
of this radius here which is clearly not
represented but
they're doing that they're making it out
of uh not to scale so that we can see
the shape that we're trying to determine
a little more easier which is
helpful but unhelpful for other reasons
you'll see in a second
if a player must hit the shaded area to
win
find and then we've got a bunch of
different questions here so let's just
take it one step at
a time first one the area of the shaded
part and then they've given us a level
of approximation
so let's think about this guy in here
the area of the shaded part
what's this extra bit um what are we
going to do with this well to make it
even easier to see what's going on i'm
going to draw
the relevant section and uh make it even
larger so that i can see the details
more clearly i'm also going to label
some stuff which will help us to
show the working and also you know be
able to understand what the steps are
and how they relate to each other
so this shape in here um how do i
represent it well you can see
it's sort of been each of these
different um radial sections in here
they're kind of um cut out like slices
of a pizza
very thin slices admittedly but that's
okay they're still the same basic shape
of course we call these
sectors as the technical term the actual
area that i'm interested in is not a
sector but is related to it's part of a
sector
and you'll see how we can use the sector
formula to specifically evaluate it so
i'm going to draw
the sector that's in a little larger and
then we can understand it better
so what i've got here you can see here
i'm going to draw my slice of
whoopsy daisy i'm going to draw my slice
of pizza like so
so here are two of the radii coming out
from the center all the way out
and then you've got this is the edge
that's really messy let's try that again
there we go that's cheating a little bit
i know but that's okay yeah the idea
that's the outer edge of our entire
dartboard
but you've also got this sort of inner
ring as well that needs to be included
so i'll just draw it like this
like so i reckon that's pretty good
and then um the particular shaded area
is this guy in here well that's way too
big let's try that again
um there we go so this is the shaded
area
i'm interested in sorry not my most
beautiful work but you get the idea all
right
so this is the area that i'm after let's
label some stuff so we can see what's
going on
you've got this uh sector let's call the
um the center o because we tend to do
that
um i don't know why i changed color i'll
leave it on that color for a second
we call that o we'll call this outer
part a b
and then we'll call this inner part c d
and now we've got names on stuff we can
describe what's going
on so i want to work out this area
in here and i hope that you can see you
can form this area by
taking the larger sector sector
o a b take that whole thing
find out its area and then subtract the
area
that is the smaller sector this o c
d that's a funny choice of acronym um
that ocd
sector in there if i subtract its area
i'm going to get the shaded area
abcd i guess in this case or abdc
let's just leave it that's fine so how
do i work out both of those well i'm
going to need to find out the area of a
sector
might be handy here to write down the
formula for the area of a sector
sector area is just going to be
half r squared theta where r is the
radius of the circle
that you're in and theta is the angle
that the sector subtends
at the center of the circle so how do i
work out each of those well some are
easier
than others the radius for instance of
the larger sector that's just given to
us
that is the radius of the entire circle
but i need to also work out a smaller
radius
i need to work out this radius in here
from
this cd arc all the way down to o
so in order to do that what i'm going to
show is this
here if i it's hard to write on that
because it's a bit dark
let's have something coming out like so
so this is that
seven millimeters that i was given in
the diagram but i'm already mixing
together units from the questions so
i'm going to write that seven
millimeters as 0.7
centimeters and when i know that the
total radius is 23
that gives me this other guy in here
this one must be 23 centimeters take
away
0.7 centimeters so by my calculation
that's going to be 22.3 centimeters
so now i have the big radius it's 23
i've got the smaller radius which is
22.3
and the last thing i need for this
formula anyway is this theta i need this
angle right
so theta you can see let's color this
with some different things
so you can see what's going on here it's
the angle at the center of that
circle so it's going to be this angle in
here right
now how do i find that the question
itself didn't just hand us the size of
that angle
you actually have to infer it using a
little bit of logic and
some some handy knowledge about the way
a dart ball works though the diagram
does kind of imply most of this right
you can see that the pizza slice the
sector that i chose
it's one of these sections many sections
that are all
as far as i can tell and there's no
information to suggest otherwise
these many equal sections all around the
dartboard right you can see
this guy and this guy and this guy
they're all the same just rotated around
now how many of them are there um you
could of course count
each of the sections and just go one two
three four and go all the way around
or you could choose the cheap and lazy
way and notice that
even though it's randomly ordered they
are numbered sequentially
um not sequentially sequential is the
opposite word they're numbered somewhat
arbitrarily from 1 to 20
you can double check yourself of course
that none of the numbers have been
skipped
so there are in fact 20 sectors of equal
width i guess of an equal angle at the
center
so if i know that there are 20 sectors
then the angle at the center
will be the entire revolution which we
know is 2 pi we're thinking radians here
divided by the 20 equal sections so
let's just go ahead
and we'll do that calculation now theta
is going to be
2 pi that's the entire thing the entire
revolution 360 degrees if you lie but
we've got to think in radians because
this is a radian measure question
because these formulas are radian
formulas
and i'm dividing by 20 because the 20
equal sections so
nice easy numbers here the factor of 2
cancels on the top and bottom
so i'm getting pi on 10. i have all the
information that i need now i can work
out the area
of this abdc little area by saying
area a b
d c is going to be and i'm going to do
these both
both of these together in one hit you'll
see why in a second it's going to be
um sector the big one uh oab
and i'm going to subtract the smaller
sector sector
o c d now part of the reason why i'm
putting these both in together
is because they have the half at the
front is going to stay the same for both
formulas and the theta is going to stay
the same for both formulas as well
because they share that angle
the thing that's different is the r
squared so
what i'm going to write is a half and
then the big
one is 23 squared
times pi on 10. so there's my half r
squared theta
the first time and then i'm going to go
again with half
and then here's my different radius what
did we say 22.3
that's squared and then pi on 10 again
so you can see here i'm going to have a
whole bunch of factorizing out
there's a factor of pi on 20 here funny
we sort of
cancel that and now it comes back and
you also get pi on 20 happening here as
well so i'm going to go
pi on 20 out the front not that you have
to do this but it just makes it easier
to put into your calculator honestly
23 squared is the bigger one and then
22.3
squared is the smaller one and at this
point
that's more or less as far as i can go
in exact terms
they've asked for the area to the
nearest square centimeter so i'm going
to take
those numbers in there and let's just do
quick
oh that's not what i wanted let's get
desmos up here
there we go okay what do we got um we
want
a pie on 20 and then i'm going to
multiply by
wrong bracket keep on doing the real one
that's better 23 squared
take away 22.3
squared so i'm getting 4.98
and i will write that first with the
decimal places and all the rest
and then i'll round off so four point
nine eight zero nine
nine five dot dot i think that'll do and
so that's approximately equal to five
square centimeters um to the i think
yeah they're one of the
nearest squares animators so nearest
unit we'll do
okay cool